[Musique]
et chérie on va ouvrir la première boîte
et je veux ouvrir la boîte de vous jean
michel godbout la boîte de vous jean
michel maire vous avez la boîte numéro
trois coups la garder ah oui jean-michel
ou est-ce que vous la donner à quelqu'un
d'avoir ce titre votre cadeau c'est bon
mais jouer un jour de naissance je le
garde trois généraux non en 1903 qu'à 1
3 novembre 3 novembre
c'est bientôt votre anniversaire jacques
tu m'étonnes vous sachiez pas passé
comme ça fait 7 ongles aura t on ne
tourne plus éduqués en tout cas cette
année je pourrai pas le rater je te
pleure ce que vous serez chez
[Rires]
jean-michel elle est le cadeau que vous
aimeriez avoir le voyage dans l'espace
je sais pas trop ce que ça veut dire
mais oui alors espace oui jean michel
vous voulez voyage dans l'espace non à
la tête de ma mère que ça n'est pas le
bisou au crapo c'est le voyage dans
l'espace
je ne sais
vous allez partir dans l'espace donc
allez-y vous avez partir tout de suite
[Rires]
sac à dos mais là c'est ce qu'on appelle
un cadeau une méga du parti issue semble
s'alléger des cochons
mais non
mentalement on va te revoir
à les regarder il va partir dans
l'espace dans un instant jean michel mr
sayed dont jean michel mr a eu son
cadeau on le retrouvera dans un instant
on va ouvrir maintenant la boîte la
boîte numéro huit formations à côté de
valérie non quoi jean michel est parti
dans l'espace mais c'est un espace très
près donc
vous allez on n'a pas tant il est rapide
et lourd
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà marca
auto
[Applaudissements]
merci merci à rouleau a toujours un site
web voilà on va dire parce que moi et re
experts spécialistes
allez merci le chien c'est bon c'est bon
jean michel hallé